so then if I understand this right that
final destination was the first
screenplay that you actually sold first
one that was the first one I sold I
wrote one it never got made but I was
actually hired to write a sequel for a
movie called Pumpkinhead which is one of
my favorites and they're remaking it now
so hopefully I can use my a sequel idea
for the sequel for the remake but I got
hired actually before I had an agent I
got hired because Brad krivoy was a
producer and yeah he was taking pitch
meetings and I wrote a pitch that he
liked and he basically hired me in
another writer right Dreyse of the
script and then they ended up the
company got bought by somebody and all
this so neither one of our scripts ever
got made
but no that was my first paying job as a
writer which was fun
that was a little crazy because you're
like wow I'm writing something that I
grew up loving so that was the first
thing that I actually sold and I and I'd
written like five or six seven scripts
before before a final destination that
never got so and rightly so for some of
them when you go back and read them it's
like whoa these are pretty pretty bad
but there's a couple of like nuggets of
ideas that I might turn into something
someday
so then what I'm just wondering how did
it happen what was the what were the
details so you're working at new lines
Oh years they know me for years you know
I had the TV I was trying to get a TV
agent and then my friend Mark Callen was
like oh this would make a great idea for
a feature so I back in the back in the
day you could actually sell a treatment
to a studio you know you didn't have to
write a whole script and because I
worked at the CIA I knew how the when
the winds would change very frequently
like I so you know something would be
hot one week and not the next week so I
was like well let me write a treatment
because it's a great concept and then
I'll some friends of mine worked for a
producer outside of the studio that had
to deal with the studio so Michael let
me work with him and their producer
partner and bring the idea back to the
studio because I knew that would give me
a better chance of getting it set up it
was what the producer attached so I you
know had the treatment but then and it
was about they were all adults and then
scream came out and I loved scream and
Kevin Lewis is a dear friend of mine but
the minute that came out it's like well
let's make them all teenagers so that I
had to go through to rewrite the
treatment to make them teenagers and
then soon it's like they just
couldn't get their head around death
being the killer they're like this it's
a great it's cool but how can you make
death a killer you that just doesn't
make any sense I'm like that's the whole
point like its its death you can't so
they Pat the suitor just kept passing on
it and finally the producers it was
Warren Zayed and Craig parry they were
like well if you don't if you pass on it
again we're gonna go to dimension which
was kind of new lines rival Miramax at
the time it's like we'll buy it so then
they bought the treatment then they
hired me to write the jerk there's the
first draft of the script and then we
went out to directors after that so it
was a pretty quick process and we sold
it the original story 97 and movie came
out in 2000 so that's a in Hollywood
time that's pretty pretty fast so when
you did the casting for it how did you
find the lead they actually new line did
all they all the casting through their
casting Department I mean I you know I'd
put a little list together like my dream
cast at the time but you know I loved
the cast that we ended up with and it's
funny because I'm friends with Devin you
know he's directing now and he's got a
new TV show on and so I directed his or
produced his first short that he
directed he's really talented guys so
we've actually reconnected in the last
few years and he's just he's just a
great guy but um it is funny because
when I was writing the movie I was kind
of you know trying to turn some of the
tropes on their heads and so there's you
know there's very few movies I had like
a final guy and it's always a final girl
so I wanted to write a movie like a
final guy in it and his character I
think is definitely stands out as you
know he's such a great actor too did a
great job and he was Casper so it's
always it's just very funny making fun
of him because he was in Casper floating
around with christina ricci and her kids
dancing ridiculous Devin if you're
watching this I would see him in so many
things like because I used to go into
blockbuster all the time yeah I just
remember you know there it was again
yeah so yeah but at that time was he
yeah he was really he was really he was
really hot then too I think he'd um he'd
oh man there's something North blank on
the name of it but um there's a group it
was some coyotes and kids in them I'm
gonna move me up but it was it was it
was a really big it was Casper then they
that when he did idle hands I think out
of hands might have been
I know that was pre or post final
destination I think it might even post
final destination but yeah he was
definitely like on everybody's like yeah
you know ones to watch list so and we
shot in Canada so we got a lot of
Canadian talent for the film as well
you